peu
[Musique]
bonjour bonjour et bien aujourd'hui
maïté nous propose sa carbonade la
carbonade de maïté farci au foie gras et
une seconde recette la carbonade
gasconne alors pour la première la
carbonade de maïté qu'est ce qu'il nous
faut qu'est ce qu'il faut il faut
d'abord un bon vin doux après nous faut
des girolles il nous faut du raisin il
nous faut du foie gras évidemment notre
carbonate de notre vaut une flèche de
vous une flèche de vous ici on appelle
une flèche de vous on a fait un quart
monade alors les girolles vous m'avez
dit peut-être dans cette recette de la
dette dans la seconde nous allons voir
alors qu'est ce que c'est que laich de
vue là c'est de vous ça se trouve c'est
des morceaux de veau qu'on retrouve dans
la cuisse moi j'en aurai une jolie dèche
oui c coupé en travers dans l'appuie
dans la cuisse c'est rare maintenant
c'est une chose traditionnel il faut
demander spécialement vous le demandez
pas ce qu'on ne coupe plus puis ça
revient cher et très bien alors une
belle tranche coupe et en large avec
l'os du milieu l'argent dieu font toute
la cuisse qui se voit très bien
eh bien nous allons voir comment nous
faisons ça oui mais c'est pas difficile
il faut la saler et poivrer
oui on hassan ont la peau avant des deux
côtés ta porte bien on a tourne toujours
pareil ça n'a pas de secret bien poivrer
et on la met à cuire et à écrire comment
et où dans une cocotte la cocotte dans
laquelle vous avez donc médias graisse
de canard ça grésille un peu là dedans
c'est bien ce soir à wil comme il a pas
mal
avant cet enfant va mettre notre gré ce
qu'on entre lèche keller énorme mais qui
va très bien contenir dans notre cocotte
regardez pas ce que cela va réfléchir en
préfecture
ali tient toujours mais l'issue est un
peu de bonne volonté on va l'arranger un
peu bon alors vous allez laisser assez
peu là vient juste de restaurer des deux
côtés parce qu'après les voir elle va
pas finir de cuire la lnah voilà on va
la tournée c'est juste accuser le pilote
et adresse
la cuisine c'est tout le nar mais là
c'est la meilleur film très très bien on
aurait dit que la latérite taille et
poubelles voilà ah oui parce que le veau
rétrécit un tout petit peu quand on est
dedans oui là exemplaire de rendre à
nous sortir tout dit tout de suite comme
ça séduit elle a été saisie et la
répression prix peu mal à sortir de la
remettre sur la place de la porte la
planche voilà très bien et on va me
changer
et ensuite c'est très facile on va
déglacer avec les fauteurs grand trop
petit sauternes
ce juge et on va le laisser réduire les
devises a couvert bien sûr pendant ce
temps pendant ce temps on va appeler
n'ont rien de réserve
as we know pelez et épépinez halle aux
grains de réserve
là il faut un peu de patience il faut de
la patience mais de toute façon pour la
cuisine il faut toujours de la patience
si on veut très bonne idée gros raisin
des raisins frais parce que c'est durant
ce bien sûr tant que l'on trouve c'est
bien mais qu'est ce que vous faites avec
la pointe de couteau on enlève les
pépins et c'est minutieux sa récit
minutieux il faut le faire avec d'un
power jet peut il faut pas matérielle
extraordinaire oui pour faire un nom
mais il faut des bons yeux et faire
attention à secourir et vous les mettez
à macérer et orléans dans le sauternes
dans les gens plus tard et du sauternes
oui faut qu'il reste un petit peu quand
même ah oui reprenez vous voilà et
maintenant notre vin a réduit oui on va
y mettre nos raisins n'aurait sa voix la
regarder sa combi de jolies
on va éviter tout ceci plein de raisin
avec leur ignorer le sens du terme
là et on va le laisser réduire encore on
va leur laisser bien bien avant le 12
juin tout doux se bat on va recouvrir à
nouveau oui et or less et on s'occuper
de notre lèche très bien oui là c'est
tout un art alors maïté qu'est ce que
vous allez faire maintenant avec cette
lèche de vaud eh bien je vais la farcir
est comme ça ici avec notre foie gras et
bien il faut il faut de les chasser pc
celle là elle est un peu juste
oui mais on va y arriver très bien il
faut la femme dans l'épaisse dans
l'épaisseur tout autour tout autour de
la journée tout autour de l'ours on va
tourner comme un manège
mais surtout il faut penser si on veut
le faire a demandé au boucher de vous
que la coupe est très épaisse ni le
froid avec plaisir oui on le trouve pas
couramment
il fait le combat et il faut le
commander bien sûr c'est une chose très
traditionnel mais qui a un peu disparu
parce que les gens pensent plus à le
faire il parce que faire ça les gens
s'amuser plus à cuisiner et voilà on
trouve ça dans les campagnes encore ça y
est la voie la coupe est partout et
après ça et après sa belle voix et m
autrefois dessus de dents et là c'est un
peu juste en savoir un petit peu oui
voilà alors maintenant on va y mettre
nos la mène deux fois la menace est
importante et quand même autrement dit
je vous l'ouvrirez vous aller glisser ça
là dedans c'est le fois dedans
là je referme non non non on va mettre
un peu oui c'est dommage et la
gaspillent en narrant la rage outre
après ça ira
bon alors l'autre côté pareil là on peut
en mettre un peu plus peut-être
on va économiser là il va pas chercher
des économies très relativise el sayed
en avant tout autour tout le tourner
dans séparé tout ce qui dépasse on a
notre honneur il va de soi que c'est du
froid du foie cru un truc cru et freezer
refermer refermer le couvercle ça paraît
un petit peu parce que c'était pas ses
pairs ou c'est moi qui ai mal coupés
mais vous en avez à peu près partout il
ya quelque chose là voilà on serre est
ensuite enfermé plus on coule encore un
petit peu au bar enfin petit ourlet je
suis très bon en couture va faire le
petit ne renferme grossir non en fait
quelques points où quelques coins retour
et ça y est est-ce qu'il faut mettre
tout de suite alors il faut que je me
force à l'adresse ici la grèce et bien
chose aussi de la daf allégresse le vin
blanc le lez allait me la milice que les
amis lorsque nous a mis dedans on va
regarder si ça fait la faire elle est
finie la wii les finis un bon dernier ne
et ensuite et ensuite on va la mettre à
cuire elle va être accrue dans la
cocotte avec nous et notre vin voilà on
va l'apporter délicatement dans notre
jeu et on va les saisons déjà bien sûr
là et voici la laisser cuire
tranquillement pour combien de temps oh
il faut la surveiller
il faut que sa cuisine à faire payer va
la fermer et on ne peut être attaqué
l'autre on va attaquer l'autre alors
voici l'autre
elle est belle aussi elle est très jolie
et on va la faire d'une différente face
au farsi avec de la farce on va la pause
et on va la salle et la poivre et
toujours pareil pendant que celle là qu
il faut pas perdre de temps dans la
cuisine il faut tout faire en suivant
voilà pour cette carbonate gasconne il
nous faut un bon un beau gâchis
alors je vais continuer peut-être à le
tourner et tourner moi je vais recouper
un petit peu plus de jabot voilà qu'est
ce que nous avions déjà dedans de la
ventrèche de la vente très ch du jambon
de l'échalote d'un petit peu de yoff
on va y ajouter de l'ail et du persil
ensuite oui et maintenant le jambon qui
commence arrivé à l'os est bien très
bien
je le mets dedans bien sûr et pendant ce
temps vous m' a ajouté la persillade que
de la ligue 1 quand même qu'on a préparé
mais on va la main accès tout dans le
saladier dans le ça je vous donne le
farsi tout de suite tout de suite la
voix des mille-iles ceci très bien là
c'est bon c'est bon ça va c'est bon
alors je vous le passez on va mélanger
on va pas salé et bien non parce que le
jambon et le jambon
alors vous allez c'est le on va mettre
la persillade
pendant ce temps j'ai peut-être mettre
la poêle à chauffer ils doivent pas
perdre de temps et ont revu on va mettre
un oeuf pour lier le tout ah oui le yen
à ces deux jaunes et blancs jaunes et
blancs levante y est voilà il faut pas
avoir peur de remuer avec les maires
c'est avec les mecs ça se remuer en les
lavant les raves les mairies et qu'est
ce que vous allez en faire de se farcir
voilà on va l'étalé ça chauffe
oui ça chauffe ça va pas mal des liens
voilà c'est facile on va le remettre sur
cette laich
là c'est tout ça vous voulez aller à cp
dessus mais bien sûr mais ensuite on va
la saisir dans la graisse de canard bleu
serait une cause bien fait cela un peu
de sel et poivre
quand même peut-être par le poivre
voulais pas me plaindre ou pas oui mais
y'a l'influent par mettre un petit peu
il faut trouver qu avec le jambon c'est
pas indispensable je crois que ça y est
vous allez pouvoir la mettre parce que
j'aurais bien que l'on agressé pour vous
faire plaisir aux normes un peu oui
10 heures seront là toujours soupçons et
voilà il rapporte de ses ligaments et on
hamm est dans la toile
là et on a couvre on l'a laissé un tout
qui peut se dire avant où la couvre tout
de suite dans les rues si on veut
d'ailleurs la course parce qu'il faut
que sa cuisine parce qu'on va pas la
tournée et bien sûr il faut qu'à la
réserve au four ou à la poêle couvert au
four ou un lapin le couvert mais je
monte à le faire c'est lors d'une
recontre si les années ben dhia delahaye
de la taille mais là on n'avait pas de
cofrentes assez grave alors on coupe
dans
nos camarades sont cuites elles sont dit
je lis alors oui les manger non et
pourquoi encore on va les finir et pour
les finir on aller flamber à notre
concurrent qu'est ce que c'est déjà ce
qu'aucune notre concurrence et d'un
petit appareil qu'on a la chance d'avoir
cet appareil qui ne se vendent pas mais
qu'on fabrique nous même est très
traditionnelle qui est très
traditionnelle c'est en forme
d'entonnoir avec une longue queue et
qu'on fait rougir dans la cheminée quand
on a la chance d'en avoir une nous avons
une fois les avances de famille au feu
alors on prend du grade lire déjà bon
oui voyez vous et on va chercher le
concurrent dans la cheminée animé le
gras de jambon que voici
voilà et qui se met à tomber il faisait
fermer tout de suite et on avance et on
arrose une autre fenêtre parce que le
gras halal à royat et voilà et sa tombe
oui et ça donne un rc lens perd faire
parce que là ça donne un petit goût de
challans voyez comme c'est tout dorures
et de jambon fois la prière et surtout
vrai en noir que ça fait c'est un côté
assez satanique avouait sa sorcière
maïté canon mais c'est excellent et tous
ceux qui aiment la bonne cuisine
je vous assure qu'ils seront très copain
avec moi et oui on va pas vous demander
comment vous avez fait pour voir
l'affluence et l'on en a remédié ne vous
inquiétez pas assez délicieux et oui
c'est pas parce que c'est noir que ce
n'est pas bon mais c'est parce que c'est
nous que c'est réussi un espèce de
caramel voilà et bien si vous voulez
faire pareil
d'abord vous pouvez essayer de vous
fabriquer un cocuron séparés puis la
recette et bien vous pouvez la demande
et fr3 aquitaine publie les recettes de
la cuisine des mousquetaires en cassette
vidéo
et quant à nous bientôt à prochain
rendez vous m'avez vous en tendant à
tous
[Musique]